and here he is the man of the hour asher
wojciechowski
32 year old has been around the block
kicks and deals the first pitch of the
game it's hit deep
back to left goes gardner at the track
at the wall
it's gone first pitch of the game one
nothing philly's gene
segura with the lead off home run it's
his fifth home run of the season
philly's up 1-0 500 hitter this year
on the first pitch when he puts it in
play 500 hitters
swing and a miss got him on the slider
2-2 and he struck him out swinging and
breaking ball down
two straight strikeouts for wojo spencer
has been throwing the ball very well at
lehigh valley as far as his numbers are
concerned and the
throwing breaking balls in fastball
counts and doing what he needs to do to
prepare for the big leagues and
swinging a miss and a high fastball two
outs here in the first
all four back-to-back walks philly's now
with two on and one out
and jankowski is coming up two-two
ball left center and down goes floreal
as gardner made the play
two-way and there they go pitch
swung on and a high pop
down from third is wade and makes the
catch right near the mound
you end the inning so wojo pitched out
of trouble
nice piece of hitting by sanchez just
stroked it into right center field the
lead off single
[Applause]
ground ball out to second that could be
two there's one
and two in time to get torres four
six really t-mac and i was
really surprised that this is uh was
turned because it was a very slow
developing play
a 6.10 era in eight starts
and he's lasted six innings in just two
of those eight
as real muto is hit by the pitch a
little glance out to wojowski
harper struck out his first time up line
drive out to right field
that's a fair ball going to the corner
going to third is real muto he's being
waved home
not a great throw in over the head of
the first cutoff man
and real muto scores it'll be an rbi
double for harper it's two
nothing fills
ground it to odor short right field
and he will get miller and that will do
it one run
one hit two men left we'll go to the
bottom of the third
there goes florio and the pitch hit le
mayhew
so no stolen base or it would have been
though the yankees have chew on and chew
out
oh two pitch coming and a fastball
called strike three
right down the shooting cut back
beautifully
and spencer howard gets john carlos
stanton for the second time
tonight
jankowski down looking
backhanded by torres fires to first nice
play
to get segura really strong play by
gleiber torres in the hole
now wojciechowski works a one two three
inning
two nothing here in the fourth here's
glebe taurus
and the pitch is swung out in the other
right that ball is high
it is far it is gone it's
labor day oh glaive tour is now on a hot
streak of hitting home runs
and like a good glaber torres is there
and the yankees now trailed two to one
[Music]
grounded and threw for a base hit past
the diving gregorius
gardner ran right through first base not
sure if gregorians
would field it so he picks up a single
and here is greg allen
that's what's rocketed in the left
center field that's a base hit
cutting it off in the gap miss jankowski
but he bobbles they're going to wave
home gardner
here's the throw he's in there it's an
rbi double for allen
and we're tied at two with two outs
gardner's gotta think i'm scoring the
whole time
inside ball four and that's two walks in
the inning
bouncer over to third backing up on his
way to second
and safe at second base he's off the bag
and the bases are loaded
gotta take another look did he stay on
michael yes i think he did
yes he did and the yankees are going to
and it challenge overturned he'd rather
have
wilson against luke williams than
alberto de bruyne
against jankowski therese will go from
first
and the pitch grounded to short
laboratories fields across the diamond
they get williams
and wilson does a good job to get out of
trouble we'll go to the bottom of the
six tied at two
tap third base could be a very tough
play
it could be a base hit torrey has felt
his best chance was to hope that it
kicked fallon didn't
so he scrambles after it's infield
single for floria
runner goes through the second
it's a stolen base for floreal rio
mutual's got a
hurry up and one hop it and floreal
easily in there
so here's stanton oh for three tonight
ground ball basic pass to diving sedora
here comes floreal he will score
it's an rbi single for stanton and the
yankees lead three to two
1-0 on odor high drive
right field miller back locking
up sia into the second deck
a two-run home run for rodol and the
yankees lead it
five to two shut the door
oh door now rookie a two-run blast and
the stadium is alive
ground ball and right between the legs
of
torres and reece with a big turn around
first and he's aboard e6 13th error of
the year for torres
inside ball four and the tying run is
coming to the plate
and ball four that'll load the bases up
well this is a sticky situation as nick
nelson
has to come in and try to get out of
this jam he's gonna face luke williams
with the bases loaded he calls two
strikes
pulled over to third under the glove of
a diving weight into left field two runs
will score
the throw is cut off and it's a one-run
game
luke williams comes through and the
fills
capitalize on the error by glaber
torres it's a 5-4 ball game
3-2 count ball
four and the bases are loaded again
faces
loaded one out top of the eighth inning
ball gets away
and here comes the tying run terres will
score
it's a 5-5 game
three and one ball four
now the go ahead run as a board for the
fills here in the ninth inning
they haven't picked off gittins fires to
second
they got him hoskins is out
one three six here's the one
two from chapman struck him out swinging
basketball up that was 100 no runs no
hinson no one left and there's the 1-1
a little tapper down the third baseline
going to be a tough play bradley throws
base it face it all the way
[Applause]
that one has driven into right field and
it's over the head
of miller
moving to third is lemayo they'll hold
them there standing stops at second
and the yankees are set up ranger suarez
is on here at the bottom of the ninth
inning with one out and runners in
second and third
and o'dour pulls it toward first
backhanded by hoskins he's coming home
and le mayhew is out at home plate and
so the defensive alignment works out
they do bunt suarez makes the play
flips to first the sacrifice successful
1-4
as sanchez is 90 feet away
ryan lamarr will pinch it here for
gartner
neither mccutcheon nor miller have great
arms
in the outfit they're playing very
shallow infield in
lamar at the plate pinch hitting for
gardner
this should get it done deep fly ball
right field miller back turns looks
and it is a walk-off single for ryan
lamar and the yankees win
6-5